Become getting rich is not an act it is a habit. So it is staying poor
It's also not an act. It's nothing just happens to you. It is a habit. Most people they
listen to a webinar they watch a video and they say oh this guy's making
Whatever how much money online I could do that and they jump into it and then they try for 3 months
And so all this thing doesn't work. Why do you think people watch reality TV? You know what?
I thought my life is a mess. But look at these people on TV
Instantly if you better buy yourself
Need motivation watch your top team with believe nation. What's that believe nation? It's Evan
My one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level talent at
Something and I want you to find it embrace it and use it to make a difference
So let's get your motivation to attend and get you
Believing in you grab a snack and chew in today's lessons from a man who went from immigrating to Canada at age
14 with zero money and not speaking any English
To failing 13 separate businesses to now becoming one of the highest paid consultant in the real estate game
He's Dan Locke and here's my take on his top ten rules of success
enjoy
Okay, let's kick it off with rule number one learn more when the first business opponent that I had it was like a
basically
He was my neighbor at a time. I was trying to be a mother business and he sold me on the concept
Oh, you need a website and I pay him some money a long story short
He's basically scared me out of like hundred fifty thousand dollars. I lost all my mom's money all the savings
And I didn't know anything about into the marketing and then right after that because that experience was so
Traumatic for me from then on everything. I do I said I want to learn in a hundred percent
so I went and at a time internet marketing I bought the corey rudl course and remember the
insider secrets to mark on the internet right that the two big binders like
600 pages I went through in two days Wow
And from then on I was just like reading
Every I forget about like reading a book a month and I was reading a book every two three days. So
That experience change how I operate and that that's hard about this hunger to learn
yeah as much as I could so I would feel I
Don't think it's a healthy thing is when I went to Tony's event. Unleash the power within yeah, I don't know
This is a healthy thing, but I always have this
Feeling of no I need to know more right? I need to know more rule number two my personal favorite
I'd value I was knocking on door and no one like I was not gonna hey, do you wanna be the Milano?
No, we don't need that. We're only a - yeah at a time. I had my mom had a friend my aunt
She had a printing business right like, you know, printing business card and wires and all that
So I went to my aunt I said why don't you know, you print a bunch of flyers
I would help to distribute in the in the neighborhood like printing service. But yeah, they're two sides are flying, right?
Between 5,000 of these. Yeah, I'll run around now. I'll distribute it on the other side. Can I put my stuff on?
Yeah, my lawn mowing service. It's like Oh, what the heck, right. Yeah. It's all been always very entrepreneurial
Yeah, you know how to you know be resourceful in the city. Yeah. Yeah
Yeah
cuz a lot of people wouldn't have even tried that cuz they'll say well I don't have the money for lawn mow or I don't
Have any of that so it stopped them, right? Yeah, it's a good proof right there that it's not about what you have
It's about what you do with what you have hundred percent. We're exerting that even at a young age. It's never lack of resources
I think it's a lack of resource fulness and and I was just resourceful. I had no money
So I had time I can put in effort and I distribute all five of your flyers I ran home
And I was just waiting for the phone. I thought I'm gonna get rich. Yeah. Oh my god, five five thousand people
I'm like, I'm gonna to get a hundred phone call or I'm gonna pour my time. I'm still going to school
I thought I'm gonna make like House Isabella's right, right
One hour no call
one day no call
Three days not a single one. Now. Let's check the flush. Get I put in a wrong number, right?
No the right number right not a single phone call on the flyer. All right, and and I learned okay
There's something that you know, you can have a great product a great service
But if you don't know how to get it out there your marketing in and get people to pay attention
No one's gonna buy from you. So I came with an idea. I thought to myself and this affected my
Philosophy for the rest of my life man is a philosophy
So I thought think back the very first client I had could pay me 20 bucks. What did I do? I
Mow the lawn first before asking anything in return. That's how I got that first $20. Right, right
Yeah, I thought let me do that again
So I ran around the neighborhood and I found one of the most probably one of the higher-end
Expensive homes in the neighborhood and I saw the lawn was like up to this high
Like high and I just found it fun a day and it just mowed and I think that this is illegal
I'm not an advocate of that, but I did that so you didn't even knock on their door, you know the whole lawn, right?
I did the whole thing
Right, and I finish the whole thing and I set at the front door waiting for the homeowner to come back
Okay, she is funny. It's a housewife she came back and she couldn't she couldn't recognize her lawn
This is this lot right? Yeah
she's 12 pi and then she drove back and she pulled what the hell is going on, right and she's like
Who are you? Like I said, you know I said just a kid
I'm trying to make you know, make some money. I provided services of fly. Oh, this is awesome
You know my husband travels all the time
He never is ever home. I can't do this stuff. Thank you so much. You make my lawn. Looks like she gave me $100 Wow
$100 right and that affected me for the rest of my life
so my business philosophy until this very day if you say one of my
Motive for for business add value first before you ask anything in return. Yeah. That's how I always approach
You know how most business people they approach somebody
yeah, they want to sell them some right right or they want to hey, man, you do something for me or
Like, you know social media people come to me all the time
Oh, they feel like just because I'm successful that I'm obligated to help them right you can show easily or so
Usually we'll just give them the chase. You got to gotta earn it. So my philosophy is any interaction with people
How can I add value to what you do? It's always
my most
Favorite the question is is what is the most important project you're working on like an ad value tune rule number three
Improve yourself many years ago when I first met my mentor
and I was
Telling him about all these businesses that I started I said
Hey, you know Alan I mean I started all these businesses and somehow I don't know man. I'm not I'm not making enough money
I'm struggling. I don't know why
My yeah, my my customers they're like cheap they're very difficult to deal with and oh man
I don't know the economy and it's kind of sucks. And I think I paid too much in taxes
I mean, I was rambling on and complaining and bitching of all these things and he said stop I
Said what is it? Stop? I
Said what do you mean shit? Stop? Is it it's very simple Dan. Let me teach you something
it said if your business sucks is because as a business person you suck I
Said what no us. No, I work hard. I said I was very defensive
I was like I learned and I try to try to do my best and and try to serve my customers said no
You suck as a business person
He said if if you've got sales problem, it means you suck as a sales person if you've got employee problem
It means it sucks to you and you are managing the business leader. It's very very simple
Remember this your business is always a reflection of you
Your business always reflection of you
nothing more
So
if you think about it, why most businesses fail, I think why most business fail it because
the
Reason the intend most people they stopped the businesses for the wrong reason
They start the business because they want to get out of a job
they started business because they want to
They want to make money, of course nothing wrong with that. They start a business
Because they think maybe there's an opportunity. It sounds like it's easy where the big money is not
It started for the wrong reason
versus they see a need in the marketplace this
Skill there's a this expertise is some valid it could bring to that particular industry
Right. There's something that you could bring to think about it. It's like if
think of starting a business like flying a plane and
You can't just say well I'm passionate I have a great idea let me fly that plane
Well, you have your food. I've you fly plane before no. Do you know what if I play?
No, do you know where you're going? No?
But looks like fun. Let me go on a plane one of the chances of you crashing very high and that's what statistics shows
90% of small business fare in the first five years, even the ones who survive after five years most of them
Don't don't pass the million dollar mark
It's just kind of surviving and that's why people go into business for the wrong reason and they go into business
without the proper training
without the skills
I could tell you when I had all those failures when I started all these crazy businesses and
why they fail it's not because the vehicle is because of me as a business person that I
Didn't have the business acumen. I didn't have the business experience. I didn't know anything about leadership marketing sales negotiation
Raising capital any these skills I have today
So everything I did it didn't work because I was a lousy business person
I sucked as a business person but a lot of them were mistakes and that's the good thing about business
you can suck many many many years when you get better you learn from it you get you suck less and
When you practice and you dust yourself off deliver mistakes, you suck even little less until whether you wake up
You say you know what? I don't suck no more and
One win in business can make up a lot of losses one win can make up for all your losses rule number four set wealth
triggers so you notice I have a lot of
Wealth triggers in my office and so it's not just decorative item. Everything means something too, right?
So I have like, you know the LK that's thought that represents personal branding. Yeah, so I can think about that like leadership
Energy and your shirt wisdom. So everything is that in my office. I wanted to call them wealth triggers. Yeah, you should this shit
Create certain type of feeling environment for me, right I was believing environments more powerful. Yeah. Yo your willpower, right?
I want it sturdy. So I have meetings you awesome on that salsa burger every week goes. Yeah. Yeah, and then have the Chinese
Kind of Friday in there. I'll see if I can translate that
basically means they kind of like the outer wall and battles one before they're the font, right and and
your decisions affect
Affect with the the outcome of the battle
Even your like thousand miles away, right? Let's rush me out. That's cold. I like the John I
Love it rule number five find mentors
I tried most things like most people I rep this success books and
Already, she's thinking Grow Rich and how to win the friends influence be her. Right, you know back and forth many times like all these
books and you know
I would get up in the morning and I would look in the mirror and say I'm successful and that would be a great day
affirmation information and and I would I would visualize
It put me in a vision board, you know, I did all that stuff right here so, you know, yes, yes, you know
All right, that's right. So it was okay. I think all those things they helped
but
Really that the turning point was when I find my first man boy
His name is Alan Alan Alan and at that time Alan was here. And one of the the he was the founder of
a ring with the investment network in Canada
Which was at the time one of the largest real estate investment network in Canada. And how did you find him?
Good question is I want to ask you that because there might be somebody listening to this or watching this that might be on their
12th or 13th failure? Yeah, right at that turning point. So it's somebody sitting there and kind of confused
How would how did you find your mentor and what would be a recognition?
Oh, I'll tell you how I found a mentor and I'll give then I'll give them the advice of where to find so
at a time I was
Just like an opportunity. Junkie. Okay. I know money's our attendees like free seminars and I would get on these like mailing lists
right and Alan
Was running one of the largest financial seminar companies in Canada. He was the first one that brought waka Kiyosaki
Mmm from Rich Dad Poor Dad. I was kinda shocked before even the Kiyosaki was famous. It was the first guy. So I
Was getting all these junk mails Direct Mail like not not Instagram Facebook right direct mail, right?
Yeah, and I would always always be fascinated
By the way, that he would write these sales letters, right and I would collect them. Mm-hmm
I would collect them put in a real punch didn't put them in a binder and I would save them and will study them
Just fascinated by the way. He communicates right?
So the copywriting on top right here and he's I remember the name Alan Jack's right? This is name and
At one time was attending a free conference or seen sitting in the back and I was watching the speaker
Jenna a gentleman sat down next to me and watching the speaker was looking at you
I was looking that's like I know there's a name. Ken. Yeah
It's just Alan Jack's Wow, and I thought no way
Yeah, no way. And I said are you Alan jacks? He said yes
I said are you the one that's hosting these events inviting these letters and it's like yes, I am going home
Right. That's my internal dialogue. I try to be calm, right?
As I'm a huge fan
Yeah, like I love what you do, and he thought I was referring to the event
But yeah, yeah, you know we'd do pretty good events. I said no no, no no, I
Study your letters here as I collect them
I tell them I I collect these letters and he was
Shocked because I don't think he's ever had anyone telling him that all right young guy
2020 someone 21 years old my pocket handing out my copy, right? Yeah, like collecting the junk mail and I
Was just faster. They said I said I said mr. Jackson
Can I buy your lunch? Mm-hmm?
And I always remember to reapply he pause
He said what the hell I gotta eat
Yeah, that was the start of a relationship Wow, and we had lunch we talked for hours
And then I afterwards I asked him to be my mentor which he turned me down
Mm-hmm, and I was again not recommending this. I was basically stalking him in his office
Why I rented office everyday if we tell you it physically go there I'll do the office
I would say anything I would pick up the trash anything. Yeah, I was just demonstrating. I want to help anything
Yeah, I don't care about money. I don't want a salary. I don't want anything and and finally a monthly that's okay
I just need to hire you just so this is this is like this is spotting me so much money
He's part of my staff fine like this young man. It's like crazy. Right and he did and I worked for him for
Almost for a year for next to nothing. That was
Funny story so we would do a lot to write mail, right?
so we stuff these envelopes and I will help stop the envelopes and
You know the envelope the stems and I would like that liquid envelope
Right and I would put the after about two weeks of that. He said Dan you can actually use water for that
Oso Oso doe it's getting poison a licking five
Envelopes like that and put the whole thing in but that's how I got started, right?
That's like how naive I was I was just hungry rule number six get good habits
We are what we repeatedly do human beings. We are creatures of habits
you notice that you kind of do the same thing the same routine over over and again and again and again see
Become getting rich is not an act it is a habit. So it is staying poor
It's also not an act. It's not something just happens to you. It is a habit. So
Let me teach you the three best habits of rich people the very first habit of rich people and that is they count
their money
Poor people don't count their money. They get a paycheck. They deposit their paycheck. They spend the money
They have no idea what the expenses are. You have no idea how the money flows
you know this poor people they
alb they have a job and wait till maybe once a year when they found out they would tax return is
The Texas that I own is how much of the pay they look at the numbers. Do you even look at the numbers?
It's just okay. All right, that's what how much I need to pay without tax return and death. Yeah, look at it
Maybe maybe once a year rich people. We don't do that. We look at our numbers regularly
We are financially literate
I'm not a numbers person. Don't get me wrong. Okay, I'm a concept guy. Okay, I'm a big-picture
thinker I'm a visionary but I am very
Very careful, and I'm very aware
How my money is flowing habit number two is they pay themselves first. Now you've heard of this before
Oh, yeah, I know then I've heard of this this before you gotta pay yourself
Do you know actually what that means paying yourself doesn't buy yourself a car. It doesn't mean taking that vacation
It doesn't mean that you know, you would you know, you go blow money on entertainment. Oh, yeah. I'm paying money myself
No
That's paying everybody else when you're buying a car you're paying the automotive motive company when you're buying a house you are paying the bank
When you are traveling you're paying the the traveling agency
You're paying the hotel you're paying the the flight company airplane company ping yourself meaning
That you put your money aside and you invest your money now
I'm not talking about being frugal, you know, if you know anything about me, you know my work
I'm not talking about being fool girl and being cheap
I'm talking about taking a pass percentage of your income and putting that aside pay yourself first and
Save it and then you invest it habit of rich people number three and that is rich people are constantly improving
Their earning ability because you might be thinking Dan. Okay, I want to pay myself first, but I'm not making enough money
I'm only making a few dollars in a month. I couldíve I couldn't even afford to pay my bills
How am I gonna pay myself first?
First of all, you gotta have the habit of paying yourself first
If you're not paying yourself first, even a tiny small percentage when you're making 30 40 50 60 100 thousand dollars a year
I guarantee you when you're making a million two million dollars a year. You're not paying yourself
it is a habit that I'm talking about and
in order to do that in order to be able to
Every single year to be able to pay yourself more and more and more and put into investments
You need to improve your earning ability
You need to find ways how you can add value to the marketplace how to add more value to the marketplace. So every single year
Your income it's going up every year if you've been you've been
Working in house in the real world and you have your own business and your income kind of stays
Flat for the last two three five years and shame on you. It means you're not learning
It means you're not thinking it means you're not growing every single year your income
You have to strive to improve that your earning ability and the rich people. We're always
Constantly looking for ways to improve our earning ability, but also looking for ways to ant leverage
To apply leverage into what we do rule number seven don't have unrealistic
expectations and why do you think so many people fail in spite of the best efforts, you know a lot of people watching this
Right now they've maybe tried different ways of making money online or building businesses
Why do you think is the the main reason why a lot of people fail I?
think that two main reasons
the first one is I think
because of the whole internet
that
they have people have this unwilling to
And so Stefan is doing this is that kind of YouTube channel and he's doing Kindle publishing and I want to do that
You know, I maybe I'll make some videos to what they don't see is how many years of effort that you put into it
so most people they
listen to a webinar they watch a video and they say oh this guy's making
whatever how much money online I could do that and they jump into it and
Then they try for three months. And so all this thing doesn't work. Yeah, right. Oh, they jump into the next thing
Bitcoin whatever now it's Bitcoin so hard, right? Oh and then and then they try that and then try for three month old
That doesn't work. They try the next thing
So I think that expectations
Unrest expectation need to lead to disappointment and failure. Rule number eight have a healthy mind and body
I saw a couple comments on
YouTube people asking or Dan do you recommend these like mine?
Stimulating our mind and hinging drugs. The answer is absolutely
Not if you follow my work, you know, I don't smoke I don't drink and I don't do drugs
I don't even drink coffee why I drink like honey green tea
That's why I drink and water and maybe from time to time
You know cook zero when I'm watching a movie or something like that. That's it. No drugs, no cigarettes and
No alcohol
Why is that because you notice a lot of times even with my own story?
My father was actually a very heavy smoker
I want to say he said hey, he was an alcoholic but he drinks quite a bit
He enjoys a glass here and there and I do notice later on when he had to stroke
He had all the when his health was in it was declining a lot of those habits contributed to that
If you don't have a healthy body a healthy mind
There's no way in hell you'll be able to sustain the stress the the pressure it takes to be successful
So I don't think you need those things
You only need those mind and hands in drugs to be successful to have more clarity and all dish
If you want to enjoy a drink here and there that's perfectly fine. I'm just saying I don't do it
I don't need to have alcohol to have a good time
And when I drink I like people if hey Dan, just a zip of beer. It's ok. Enjoy
They don't taste good to me quite frankly. I mean, they taste like right they don't even taste good to me
So I don't enjoy I don't need those things to have a good time if I have a good time good
Company good friends good conversation. I have a good time and I don't need to get high to do too
I get high on doing what I love I get high on just life
I get high on being the impacted people rule number nine up your thermostat
Alright great ideas alone are not enough why great ideas along are not enough to change our lives
You see one of the great mistakes that most people make is they are tending to change their body
There are chairman telling to change the relationship. They are telling to change the income their finance
They are tending to change something outside of themselves in
Searching something that's inside with themselves
Some people see themselves as conservative and unsaved are they gonna do anything crazy? Are they gonna go bungee jumping or skydiving?
No
Unless you drunk or something like that
So you're not gonna do anything crazy or Act not unless you're drunk. Now you might say it's the alcohol
But really it's just you finally getting permission to be yourself. The alcohol is just an excuse if
You are playful. If you're fun, if you're outrageous, you're gonna talk differently gonna move differently. You're gonna dress differently
Maybe in a red suit
and
you're gonna do things differently and there's no right or wrong, but most of us have
Trapped ourselves in an old self-image and never really update who we are today
So then when you go and learn a new skill when you go learn a new ability a new idea
But we're stuck in this self-image. This is who I am and that's why we never surpass it
Let me give you a metaphor. This would make sense for you
Let's say in this room that we set the thermostat at 70 degrees. Let's say that 70 degrees. It's a metaphor
It's a what?
Metaphor for your comfort zone which is also known as your self-image
your comfort zone and
most people have goals that are
larger
They're more than their self-image and that's why most people don't get to their goals unless they alter and or expand their self-image
So 70 degrees is your comfort zone 70 degrees. It's your body
Not your goal not where you want to be eventually, but what you're comfortable with
70 degrees is your the amount of love and passion and connection you have in your personal intimate relationship
Again, not your goal
But you know
What where you live with what you live with regularly 70 degrees is the amount of money that you need to make to be comfortable
Not your goal what you're comfortable with. Let's say the temperature drops to 65 degrees
Now what happens is your brain goes? Hey, hey. Hey, I'm a 70 degree or not a 65
the heaters kicked on
You feel this a drive and this dis urge and you want to do something about it by show of hands how many I've ever
had experienced part of life
Maybe your body maybe your income maybe your relationship where it dropped and you fell it's not good enough and you fell this
Incredible try to do something about it. Yeah, but without way I'm gonna say oh, yeah. Oh, yeah and
from there and you try something and it doesn't work and you try something else and it doesn't work and you try something else and
It doesn't work
Now after a while nobody wants to be a disappointment
No one no one wants to feel like a failure in their lives. So what some people do is
They lower the thermostats they lower their expectations
They make their goals smaller
More realistic more reasonable
Don't get your hopes up or you'll be disappointed
Well, you know maybe
Maybe not. I'm not a 70 70 degree
Maybe our 65 degree air
Look at those 70 degree people
so arrogant, so
Fooled themselves, they're probably workaholics anyway
I'm being smart. I'm cutting back. I'm downsizing I don't want to burn myself out. I don't have more balance in my life
Now before you know it they're 62
They only at 58 now, by the way
When you add when they add when they ask if th today Hara hang around with 70 degree people
No, they hang around with 50 degree people
So they feel better about themselves on a regular basis. Why do you think people watch we are the TV?
You know what I thought my life is a mess look at these people on TV
Instantly if you better buy yourself
Now but you're at tax obviously, you're not like that. You're an overachiever. Yes. You're no achiever
So when it's when it's supposed to be a 70 degrees, yes, 65. What do you do you do something about it?
Yes, you don't settle you try it. Try something else. It doesn't work. You try something else. It doesn't work
You try something else. It doesn't work
You don't settle you don't give up and you don't give it if you hit a wall you go around it you go
Over and you go under it, whatever it takes you do it
and
And do you stop at 70 degrees? No, you keep going until you hit 80
85 90
91 92 93
99 degrees and your brain goes hey, hey. Hey, what do you think you're doing up here?
You're not an a/d degree. Who do you think you are get back to where you were and
Suddenly you realize you're outside of your comfort zone and
then the heater stopped and you lose your drive and
you begin to self-sabotage yourself and
You stop doing what got you there in the first place and you start doing some dumb things
making some dumb decisions
until you get back to exactly
Where you think you deserve to be?
Now how many of you all know? I'm sure none of you have done this
But how many of you have seen other people sabotage themselves?
Yeah, I thought so I thought so
You see the strongest force in human personality is the need to remain consistent
with how we see ourselves the
Strongest force in human personality is the need to remain consistent with how we see ourselves
so the image that we hold of ourselves controls our successes and our failures and
Also impacts every single area of our life and rule number 10
The last one before some very special bonus clips is have a sense of urgency
The average human lifespan is 75 years
One-third of your life is spent sleeping and outer third of your life is spent on watching TV movies drinking and partying
traveling spending time with family and friends playing video games
Commuting to work buying groceries paying the bills being stuck in traffic
Waiting in line mowing the lawn cleaning up the house and doing laundry
25 years left
In the first 18 years of your life you are growing up you are learning to walk eat
run and talk
You are totally dependent
Parents and going to school because he can't really think for yourself. Call your own shots
Or know how to be your own person. That means you have
approximately seven years to make your dreams come true and if you have a job you probably
Spend most of that time working for someone else instead of building your own dream
life is too short to waste time on people who don't lift you up or
Inspired you life is too short to be living
Somebody else's dream life is too short to wait life is too short not to take chances
Life is too short to wake up with
Developed a sense of urgency into pursuit of success and freedom you must
Step up to live life on your own terms
You
Now I've got two very special deadlock bonus clips on how to decide to be successful and just keep trying that
I think you're really gonna enjoy but before that I want to make sure we're moving from
Consuming a video to now actually taking action in your life for your business
so I've got three questions for you to ask yourself and in the answers write them in your journal to yourself discuss them with a
Friend or leave them down in the comments below
Ready, here we go. Question number one
What triggers can you put in your environment to steer you towards success question number two?
What will you do to up your thermostat and raise your standards and question number three?
What is the most important habit that you need to improve right now? Thank you guys so much for watching. I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in yourself and whatever. Your one word is much. Love. I'll see you soon, and enjoy the bonus clips
While was born in Hong Kong, right, so I
emigrated to
Canada
When I was 14 years old with no money, no connections
And couldn't speak a word of English so you can see when even when I still today I speak with an accent
I'll leave you an accent
so
My mom and dad because they were having some some issues and so my mom decided that she didn't want to stay in the relationship
That's why we emigrated to Canada and the time was so young. I was kind of like a punk kid
Yeah, I had no direction. Yeah, I was getting your fights and hanging around with the wrong gang of people and it's just always
getting into trouble right and
so my mom my mom and dad got divorced when I was 16 years old and
And surely after that my dear went bankrupt in Hong Kong and the time my mom and I we were living in a one-bedroom apartment
Okay in one of the worst neighborhoods in Vancouver Wow
So I remember I was my mom would stay in the in the bedroom
I would sleep in the living room fight with sew on the floor
Basically, I remember one day after Scott went home door was locked and I knocked on my mom's door
She was on the phone with somebody. I didn't know who but I heard that she was crying on the phone
And it's like hey mom mom is everything. Okay. I was like, oh I know everything so don't worry about it and afterwards
Basically, I found that she was on the phone with my dad and my dad basically my mom. He went bankrupt
He couldn't send us money anymore. It's at first he was sending us some allowance. Right and I my mom is a very
very
positive
Happy person. Like she's like one of those people that
She's friends with everybody. Like I said, no enemies right just a sweet sweet sweet person. So and
I'll never forget the face on my mom like that face that facial expression
just so hopeless and
She was like now I'm gonna do I've been housewife all my life
How am I gonna raise this kid with with no money with little savings and shoots
She wasn't working at that time, you know, then you're 16 at this time as well. 16 17 about 17
and from then on I said to myself I
Don't care what I have to do. I don't want to see that face on my mum anymore. Yeah
Yeah, I don't care what it takes. I don't care what how hard after work
That's I think the turning point the planet a seat right where I know that as a man
We want to provide for the family of course, and we want to but I think as a man we cannot
protect the people that we love if we don't have the resources, right it could be financial, but if we don't have the resources and
That's when I made a decision. I'm going to be successful because
Unless I'm successful I cannot
Provide for the people that I love I cannot protect the people I love and that was it from then on that's the only child
And that's when I started my first business if you ask me the question right Oh Dan
What why what kept me going was the motivation?
There's no motivation every time I fail in a business venture, I was further and further in debt
So by the time I feel I feel 13 businesses before having my first success
After you fail so many businesses I was so I was in so much debt if I was just to get a job
I would never pay that off. It would take me 20 years to pay that off
So it's more like I'm back to the corner. I have no way out. I gotta make it work
So now I thought to myself I just gotta keep trying
And if I can just make it and then it'll be fine. And that's exactly what it is. So, I mean if you're in debt
that
Don't think about if you are I want to save a few pennies
Let's not join the Starbucks coffee in the morning if there makes a difference. It's not gonna make a difference
You need to focus on wealth creation
So you make more money, then you can wipe out the debt in a short period of time, right?
Now turistic world domination honey Empire right? I'm grateful and
Why I'm here I think because I am so open I wanted to think and see it's a bloody brief life
All of you have the potential for enormous
success if you want to know what garyvee DJ khalid oprah, and others know about
Empire building that most people miss check out the link in the description for a free bonus video